another full minute of logos over the
past year I spent a cumulative total of
almost three hours on nothing but movie
company logos so if you think we're
gonna stop sending them think again
Comcast as a fellow earbud a holic I get
having headphones in all the time but
even I would take them out if my entire
office was congratulating me on
something damn in 42 seconds with no
dialogue we get the entire set up for
this plot and even some character
development as a movie ever finished
with negative sins before because hahaha
you knew what he meant face also two
hours
I know Nathan's absurdly wealthy and all
but unless this dude's been flying in
circles there's no way he'd have enough
land to take that long to fly three
Nathan one of the richest men in the
world is somehow unable to build a
helipad that is a far enough a way to
keep his secrets and be doesn't make
visitors walk through deliverance to
reach the building isn't this something
you should tell your passengers before
they depart the helicopter
what if Caleb it just walked out of the
copter with his head up high hey any
reason you're super sophisticated card
entry AI can't prepare you for your
picture to be taken or maybe even a
video screen for reference the picture
kiosk at the mall has more advanced tech
than this shut the front door no
seriously you have no reason to know it
will automatically shut shut the front
door only its general looks and poe
dameron together at first also this is a
kind of terrible place to hang your
heavy back I mean training outside and
all of nature's glory is great until the
rains come and your equipment gets all
moldy cement and glass walls a dozen
dangling light bombs and a cow skull on
the wall basically all the design trends
I hate in one roof while the
accommodations are amazing this TV that
will be used to spy on AVO while caleb
himself gets spied on is unbefitting of
a rich person come on Nathan this is
supposed to be luxurious not looking to
boss's blase Abed behavior brings
bothersome backs wet bedspread okay it's
not standard what can I tell you Caleb
you don't have to sign it not sure I
understand why Nathan wouldn't disclose
a little bit of info to Caleb to entice
in to sign Caleb understandably just
wants to know he's not walking into some
weird week of being forced to Casilla
even though his entire empire is digital
and can easily accommodate some sort of
electronic signature nathan has Caleb
sign a paper and eh how does she know
the interview is over wait so all the
channels are a slightly different
version of the same show damn
this must be Comcast I understand it'll
become a crucial plot point and that
maybe it's a sign of Nathan's paranoia
but isn't Nathan also smart enough to
know you could do a partial lockdown
when powers down without endangering
anyone else in the facility by locking
them in the room fine art I couldn't
open the doors in my bedroom that's a
security measure automatic lockdown
otherwise anybody could just open the
place up by disabling the Jews so you're
telling me this guy put a security
measure in place that might trap him
inside his own building or even outside
what if he's out punching the heavy bag
and this happens he's got all this money
and advanced technology and couldn't
come up with a better system and now we
need audio reminders that Ava's an
Android but why does it make this sound
when she turns her head when the rest of
her body is completely silent do you
want to aim it only took Caleb two dates
to get friend-zoned
I spent a long time in the hospital
afterward and I got into coding it's the
old story of parents die and horrible
car crash kid spends a year in a
hospital and gets into coding the other
thing about these plot convenient power
outages that bothers me is why does he
not have a backup power source that
Canon leased completely run the most
important systems like security and
surveillance the man is rich beyond
measure
wouldn t have a redundancy built into
the system you shouldn't trust anything
he says and if we made a list of books
it looks about which we're both now it
would form the ideal basis of a
discussion I love the scene because the
very reason Caleb is here to figure out
if Ava has consciousness is confirmed
right now and he has a choice to tell
his alcoholic boss about it or be the
good guy and not tell him about it we be
accidentally inspires the set design for
HBO's Westworld I thought that search
engines were a map of what people were
thinking but actually they were a map of
how people were thinking um yeah I was
definitely thinking about how Brazilian
donkey orgies work yesterday Jesus
Christ do you think Ava would already
know what kind of wig dress stockings
combination would give Caleb a boner so
that he'll help her escape but this is
taking forever orders aren't that hard
Ava I mean wait discount Natalie Portman
I'm wondering if you're watching me on
the camera
and I hope you are able is a fantastic
character she's playing Caleb like a
fiddle it's a wonder to behold
how I know what she's up to and I'm
already like leave me in the building
when the security system shuts down and
locks me inside forever I love you hope
everything works out for you on the
outside how your micro expressions are
telegraphing discomfort I am not sure
you'd call them micro this is the part
of the Turing test where Caleb tries to
assess if Ava knows he's talking about
his dick also Fifty Shades of AI robot
sturbation also this reminds me of the
movie sliver god damn you for making me
remember that why is that your thing
because you did a detailed analysis of
all racial types and you
cross-referenced that analysis with a
points-based system no you just
attracted to black chicks nerds planing
core shadowing also we're just Nathan
get all this fresh food I mean this is
salmon right does he have the food
delivery service go through the same
land a helicopter a mile away and follow
the river process that Caleb went
through or does someone parachute crates
of food in along with the beer supply
okay he let his mind go blank and his
hand go where it wanted apparently that
happens a lot in Hollywood I'm Kirk your
heads of warp drive engage intellect
engage was a Picard thing do you even
Star Trek bro since we know Ava is
causing these power cuts and we know
that she's doing it by touching
induction plates and because I eat when
I don't write sins for a long time I
should note that Ava doesn't touch the
thing that causes the power cut until
after the power cut officially starts
also why is there a charging station on
the stool she sits on the movie never
really is clear about where all the
access points are but there's clearly
one on the stool like an iPhone user who
needs three different chargers because
those things lose juice so fast you've
got to make your entire living space
dedicated to keeping the battery working
don't you think it's possible that he's
watching right now the blackouts were
orchestrated so he can see how we behave
when we think were observed this is
pretty good guessed by Caleb here but
why did he say this now if this is his
suspicion and why would he lie to Nathan
in the first fucking place if I reverse
the power fuck it overloads the system
you're causing the cuts in a movie full
of twists and turns this is so obvious
it almost feels like it shouldn't be
true but once you find out it is a by
causing the power cuts then you have to
wonder how neither Caleb nor Nathan
already figured this out
not bad at all in fact the similarity of
how Alex garland lingers on natural
beauty and technological beauty is
stunning and full of thematic meaning
this is an artist in complete control of
dynamic visual storytelling one of the
most confusing ly joyful movie moments
of all time I'm taking another sanur
when visiting beautiful Norway be sure
to take in the beautiful mountains the
many beautiful act break mountains
mountains are sure in act 3 so sayeth
Shakespeare what's your earliest memory
well actually it's a memory of
kindergarten it was a kid by how does
she know that this seems like something
that Caleb believes is his earliest
memory so what kind of facial giveaway
would tell Ava that he's lying when he
doesn't think he is at this point if
Nathan can't figure out that Ava's doing
this I'm really beginning to wonder if
all that alcohol has killed his brain
cells responsible for recognizing
obvious why did you make a vow the
better question is how he kept it a
secret there's no possible way that one
person alone crafted this level of
mechanical and computational intricacy
if Ava existed there would be hundreds
of people who had a hand in making her
and many more who would know she was
around
[Music]
Confucius she the good deeds a man has
done before defendant Promethean someone
went at the Promethean school of getting
drunk on things the last third of this
movie hammers home that Nathan's top
technology is relying on a goddamn
keycard instead of any biometric
security to get around the compound I
mean I used to keycard for clocking in
at my last retail job across a and no
security on the computers either are we
sure Nathan isn't trying to get her
thankfully nathan has all his passed a
eye tests filed neatly on his computer
for Caleb to get whatever exposition he
needs for the given moment
kyoko might not understand english but
she understands that it's now time to
reveal she's AI so we can keep this plot
plotting she 3p up I don't know man I
woke up this morning to a tape of you
slicing your arm open and punching the
mirror wait was that real how did that
level of injury not require medical
attention
did he stitch himself back up it allows
me to do this in full view of you both
place a new camera and battery-powered
of course what exactly is that camera
pointing at though the wall how could it
ever get a good enough angle to see and
hear everything also
how did he know Caleb would watch it
from this angle he's got multiple angles
to choose from also also how would Caleb
have seen a camera in Nathan's hand
anyway also times 3 ripping up her
picture was totally unnecessary
remember when Nathan showed up to the
room in the first place he was already
in a perfect position to put the camera
where he did without anyone noticing why
go through all that trouble plus not
that it matters but there's no way for
him to know that Caleb would be watching
also times for the sort of diversion
would have been even better if we got to
see it the first time rather than
cutting ominously to a Jackson Pollock
painting like the movie did when this
came up it would have been fun to see
Caleb's perspective and to see if the
diversion would have fooled us the
viewer I mean how could this be the
angle of the camera Nathan hidden here I
mean he's right at the glass in the shot
but here the camera appears to be way
behind this am I missing something in
the perspective it's hilarious how
Nathan needs to see three different
angles of Ava walking around the hallway
to confirm what the very first camera
angle already told it oh that's cute the
Fembots re-enacting the end of lost in
translation ex machina sex machina ex
machina not that this at to compute a
moment is it powerful in all but are we
supposed to believe Ava reprogrammed her
this quick through some sort of whisper
touch therapy damn it Nathan create her
with a glass chin or something I thought
this was a robot not flat Amira
Klitschko the structure of this movie is
one of my favorite things about it but
aren't we past the session title cards
at this point within the context of what
just happened the use of one here makes
zero sense I don't doubt that Nathan
throws a mean right hook that would lay
Caleb out for a while but the fact that
he wakes up just as Ava arrives is
suspicious at best not that we can
really show you the visual evidence with
all the nudity and such but there's no
way Ava could fit this other Android
skin on herself this perfectly the
shapes and tones are different and at
the risk of being too observant I'm not
even sure the carpet actually matches
the carpet pretty impressive that Nathan
won't himself up change shirts then
re-stamped himself because this is a lot
lower and to the left then we're Ella
actually got it like a boss Ava leaves
Caleb locked in the building fulfilling
her mission to escape the power of
boners officially strikes out and for
whatever reason I can't be happier about
it how does he even even know where the
exit is she's never been out of her room
and this compound seems like it's
confusing us and if Kyoko gave the plans
couldn't we have seen some lesbionic
data transfer don't worry dude
apparently you've got an endless supply
of booze to help transition you to a
sweet peaceful death
a total Donal so the power went out so
Ava could escape at 10 p.m. and the
helicopter was coming at 8 a.m. the next
morning let's say if I spent a little
extra time getting her skin and hair on
but 10 hours this helicopter pilot must
have zero questions about who he's
picking up you mean to tell me he didn't
think he was picking up a man by the
name of Caleb today well we're off
hopefully you know reprogram your AI
which is the same as killing you do you
have a name yes Ava
he named you must be special limitless
resource vocal and facial interaction
you hacked the world's cell phones this
is wrong however you would not be
wasting your time if you were dancing
with her what is that kid over there
where that's a double deep V from our
out of bounds collection it's pretty
advanced stuff
buried in these walls is enough fiber
optic cable to reach the moon and lasso
it you want the moon just say the word
and I'll throw a lasso around it and
pull it down
um I invented post-its question - what
is a capital sevilla that's gonna leave
a mark